Good morning, Hank; it's Tuesday.
It's question Tuesday, the day that I answer
real questions from real Nerdfighters; let's
get right to it.
Why is Hamlet's father also named Hamlet?
Just some old-fashioned Shakespearean doubling,
by the way that'll be discussed in detail
in next weeks CrashCourse Literature.
Do you think the TFiOS movie is actually good
or do you feel obliged to say that because
it's based off of your book?
That's a good question; to be totally honest
if I didn't like it I would still try to find
nice things to say about it, like "Oh, the
set design is amazing" or "Man, that Ansel
Elgort sure looks good in a Rik Smits jersey."
But, in fact, I actually love the movie.
Now I might be wrong.
I am not at all objective, but, yeah, I love
it.
Do you think people who read are more empathetic
than those who don't?
Yeah, there are actually studies that show
a correlation between empathy and reading,
at least when it comes to literary fiction.
Where do you stand on elbows?
I don't; I only stand on my feet.
I'm not very coordinated.
I don't watch your videos, why should I?
Look, I don't want to criticize anyone but
that is a terrible question Tuesday question
because if I answer it, you definitionally
won't hear my justification for why you should
watch my videos because you don't watch my
videos.
But this brings up a bigger question: How
do you get to the people that aren't inside
the camera?
Maybe there's no one inside the camera; maybe
I'm just staring into the void.
Oh god, I feel an existential crisis coming
on.
Thoughts on the ocean?
I don't know, the tide goes in, the tide goes
out.
What does it even really matter anymore?
Are there more stars in the universe or grains
of sand on earth?
Well, see that's an interesting and beautiful
question that makes me grateful to be able
to apprehend the universe.
Suddenly I've been lifted out of my funk!
I think there are more stars.
More stars than there are grains of sand on
earth and there are a lot of grains of sand!
Anyway you can find more info in the dooblydoo.
How are you enjoying participating in The
Art Assignment?
Oh, it's so fun; it's the most fun I've had
in a long time.
It actually reminds me of the early days of
Vlogbrothers because there's this tight-knit
community, like, doing projects together and
responding to each others work; it's just
really, really awesome.
How excited are you for the Divergent movie
in two weeks?
I am "already-bought-my-tickets-for-opening-day"
excited.
What are your predictions for this years Indycar
season?
How did you guys find out that I'm a secret
fan of Indycar?
Anyway I think the Indie 500 is gonna be won,
for the second time, by Tony Kanaan and I
think the series title is going to go to Will
Power, and yes that is his real name.
Can you say DFTBA in French?
I can try.
(in a terrible stereotypical french accent)
D-F-T-B-A (laughs).
Why do writers use symbolism?
OK, let's say that you have a headache and
you want to tell someone about it and you
say "I have a headache" and other people are
like "Yeah whatever, everybody gets headaches".
But your headache is not a regular headache;
it's a serious headache.
So you say "my brain is on fire" to try to
help these people understand that this is
a headache that needs attention.
That's a metaphor, right?
And you use it so that you can be understood.
Now let's say you want to take those same
imagistic principles but apply them to a much
more complex idea than having a headache,
like for instance, the yearning that one feels
for one's dreams.
Then you can see the dream but you can't cross
the bay to get to the green light that embodies
your dream.
And you want to talk about socio-economic
class in America is a barrier, a bay-like
barrier some would say, that stands between
you and the green light and makes that gap
unbridgeable.
Now you can just talk about that stuff directly
but when you talk about it symbolically, it
becomes more powerful because instead of being
abstract, it becomes kind of observable.
So I think that's why, all right, what's the
next question?
Who has the best butt- you or Hank?
I don't think either of us has the best butt;
the best butt I've ever
personally seen is actually Wil Wheaton's.
Wait, did I just think that or did I say it
out loud?
Have you ever dreamed to be a pizza?
Mmm, no that's one of those dreams that seems
initially promising but in fact I think would
be a horrible nightmare.
Like just imagine smelling like pizza and
knowing that you would taste like pizza but
then also knowing that if you eat yourself,
you will die and ergo not be able to ever
eat pizza again.
What are you most excited about right now?
What a great question!
That's something I should ask myself everyday.
I think right now it's The Art Assignment,
but I wanna know what you're most excited
about, so let me know in comments.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.